bonsoir baraquements kenya merci d'être
avec nous quand vous voyez ces centres 1
à nice et un ville française
complètement vide 1 58 personnes pour
4000 dos en tant que britannique un
vivement au royaume-uni qu'est ce que
vous vous dites ça que je suis très
attristé d'entendre cela le vaccin
astrazeneca oxford est sûre il vous
protégera il vous sauvera la vie et il
est très décevant d'entendre que les
français ne veulent pas ou prendre le
vaccin astrazeneca
je demanderai au gouvernement français
de renforcer ses efforts afin de
communiquer d'enseignés de rassurer le
peuple français ce vaccin leur sauvera
la vie et changera il faut changer la
façon dont on propage informations sur
le vaccin
il n'est pas dangereux quand certains
cas très rare il ya des liens entre eux
des caillots sanguins et le vaccin mais
c'est une chance sur un million
comment s'y est pris nos gouvernements
chez vous parce qu'il ya eu des soucis
d'ailleurs c'est parti de là on les cas
de thrombose au royaume uni il a
d'ailleurs été arrêtés on en reparlera
après puis déconseillé aux moins de 30
ans c'est e quoi grâce ou à cause du
gouvernement français grâce au
gouvernement britannique ou alors plutôt
les britanniques sont tout simplement
peut-être moins sceptique envers la
vaccination
nous avons le même problème en une
grande famille ce qui arrive en france
arrive également dans les autres régions
du monde
de ce que nous faisons au royaume uni
répétons-le des messages mesure est
raisonnable c'est caillots sanguins sont
très rares et d'autre part si le
contracte la ovide 19 alors cela peut
également closes et l'apparition de
hockey sanguins les fumeurs les
personnes qui reçoivent le mans de
contraception les personnes qui prennent
l'avion ont tous ont un risque augmenté
plus élevé 2 qu'elle s'engage donc si
l'on compare ce vaccin avec d'autres
causes telles orientations la fréquence
des cas le vaccin est plus sûr et sauve
la vie face à la cofidis 9 oui parce
qu'on rappelle une évidence peut-être
pour vous mais la phrase est né car
c'est le pilier de la vaccination au
royaume uni ils disent que c'est ainsi
que pfizer et modern art où nous avons
distribué plusieurs millions de doses et
ils sommes très prudents avec tous ces
vaccins
mais comme je l' ai déjà dit ce qui est
important c'est que le gouvernement
français doit encourager ses citoyens ce
vaccin qui est une bonne mesure contre
attendu et il faut donc s'y faire
vacciner aussi rapidement que possible
il est rennais en moins réservé aux plus
de 55 ans en france est déconseillé aux
moins de 30 ans au royaume uni est ce
que cela a du sens pour vous le royaume
uni a adopté un principe de précaution
nombre de cas de problème de thrombose
ont expliqué très rare
surviennent chez les personnes plus
jeunes donc afin d'être soudan lui-même
et jusqu'à l'extrême
il a décidé que les personnes de moins
de 30 ans recevrait d'autres plateformes
de vaccins c'est à dire des vaccins du
type taser au moderna et que les
personnes plus âgées de plus de 50
depuis de 30 ans recevrait les autres
vaccins mais également le vaccin
astrazeneca une bonne communication des
informations scène c'est très important
en gagnant on a vu ces images on va
certainement d'ailleurs les revoir dans
quelques instants d'une angleterre
libéré johnson d'ailleurs tous fiers
qu'il tend une bière dans le centre du
pays
ça veut dire quoi qu'il n'y a quasiment
plus de mort du co vide au royaume uni
quelle est la situation la maladie et
l'été c'est dû à la qualité existent
encore envoyé une ville c'est malheureux
pour moi hier dans un espace fermé peu
ventilée avec d'autres gens c'est très
risqué pour une personne le premier
ministre est un homme politique et non
pas un scientifique est donc ce message
tout comme celui de malema cran et que
la situation va s'améliorer
moi en tant que scientifique je vous
répète d'être prudent de faire attention
de ne pas encourager les gens à se
rassembler en intérieur nathan des lieux
peu ventilée car c'est là que la
contamination se fait et bien sûr
lorsqu'on a bu de l'alcool
la gare de baisse et on peut douter que
commencer à prendre les gens non et ses
bras chanter ensemble
embrasser les gens ce sont les
comportements risqués donc il ne faut
pas encourager les gens à boire tout au
moins à boire dehors et à ne pas baisser
la garde
en tant que scientifique justement est
ce que vous vous méfier grandement des
alors le variant angles et voilà vous y
êtes habitués évidemment mais on parle
surtout aujourd'hui nous varions indien
par exemple même si les frontières sont
fermées hier ce que c'est quelque chose
qui vous inquiète
les variants me préoccupe quelle que
soit leur origine
car certains de ces variants pourrait
être plus contaminateur il pourrait même
contourné les anticorps développé par le
vaccin pourrait également être
infectieux nous le ferions bien sûr
avoir de la chance et ne trouvait avec
des variants away we go moins dangereux
qui deviennent dominant mais nous devons
faire attention aussi invariants plus
dangereux à part et qui est plus
contaminant qui est plus virulent qui
contourne le vaccin alors il faut
essayer de le contrôler l'une des façons
de le faire
you look ionis et que l'union européenne
et le royaume uni et les etats unis
devrait se rassembler avec lone ces deux
vont interrompre le système des brevets
temporairement et permettre ainsi de
distribuer le vaccin est de produire les
vaccins dans le monde entier très
rapidement afin d'être distribuées
rapidement c'est une urgence mondiale un
appel aux dirigeants de l'union
européenne du royaume uni et des êtres
de se tourner vers les compagnies
pharmaceutiques et de leur demander
d'interrompre de mettre en pause en
suspense et ses brevets merci beaucoup
baraque comme en gagna d'avoir été avec
nous en direct du royaume uni ce soir